so one of the great things about being
an entrepreneur is that you don't have
to pretend to be someone you're not you
can build the culture around things that
you care about build your own value
system you have to pretend to be a suit
in an office
the funny thing is that i don't really
feel very successful i know i've been
lucky to build a company and that
company got sold for a lot of money but
in my own head i still beat myself up
and i think come on you haven't actually
contributed something to the world
you've got to do something that's more
meaningful make sure we don't screw up
the next 10 20 years i think that's
quite a good tension if you can make
sure that you channel it in a positive
way and not something that was when your
head feels like a negative thought
[Music]
lastminute.com was really one of the
first e-commerce companies in europe we
had to convince people back in 1998 that
we were gonna buy stuff with their
credit cards on the internet can you
imagine that isn't there an awful lot of
pressure on you now because this has
become a major company there's always
been a pressure on us but um it's no
worse than it's been for the last couple
of years
so hard when you're in a startup because
your personality is part of how you
market and communicate but if i look
back i think i put myself out there a
bit too much
when the stock market collapsed and our
share price went from five pounds 35 to
about 19p i got a lot of attention in
the media and i got a lot of handwritten
letters i got 3 000 letters people
writing to me telling me i was an awful
person for taking their money i was
naive in dealing with the media and i
was naive a bit in thinking we could
attract all this attention and not reap
the consequences of that so
be yourself build things around the
values that you have but hold a little
bit back
[Music]
so in 2004 i just left my company
lastminute.com and i was taking a few
months off and i was in morocco with my
new boyfriend and i fell out of a car i
wasn't wearing a seatbelt we skidded off
the road i broke 28 bones and i had a
stroke
i had to then spend pretty much the next
two years in hospital and the next
probably two years after that in
hospital in my own house recovering from
that cataclysmically bad event
i was pretty out of it for a long time
in hospital but i had decided i was
going to start another business before i
had the accident called lucky voice it's
karaoke business and the guy i was going
to start the business with used to come
to me in hospital and start showing me
kind of designs and drawings and all the
things we were going to do i was
completely high on morphine and i don't
really remember anything that i said to
him but it actually was pretty important
for me because trying to rebuild your
body but at the same time you want to
get your brain back a bit too and i
didn't want to be slowly wasting away
just focusing on whether i could stand
up
i built an online e-commerce business
you know pretty much most techie thing
you could do and then all of a sudden
it's building bars in the real world but
i think being imaginative in how you
build your life in your career is really
rewarding and actually quite important
in terms of how we build resilience as
human beings
i am the worst karaoke singer you can
possibly imagine i pick things which you
can't really massacre and now post the
accident i often sing elton john i'm
still standing for obvious reasons
inspiration and things can come from all
kinds of surprising places i've never
really had a plan don't tell anyone but
i would really urge you to be
open-minded about how you build your
career and about opportunities
so always take the call always be
opportunistic always be open-minded and
talk to people and meet people and don't
feel like you have to have a set way of
doing things
the incredible thing about being an
entrepreneur and understanding a bit
about technology is that you see how
quickly things can change and how
innovation is possible you don't have to
be the person doing the coding you can
be the person working in any aspect of
technology so don't shy away from
technology because it can help us solve
the big problems
that cat
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
subscribe button and click the bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video